الى هذه الصور في وسط الطريق والتي هي
تعكس الواقع من
المتطوعين الذين يقومون في هذه الاثناء
وعلى مدار الايام بتحضير الشاي وايضا
القهوه للعاملين ولكل الذين يريدون او
يمرون في المدينه وكما نرى ايضا هنالك
مجموعه الان من الشبان الذين حضروا من عده
مناطق الى هذه المنطقه وهم الان مع ساعات
الفجر الاولى
منهم من يستريح ومنهم من كان في الورشه
ينتظر عينه او برهه من الوقت ثم بعد ذلك
ينتقل وايضا على جانب الطريق هذه الصور
لهذه الاواني التي يطبخ فيها كما نشاهد
الان وهي للشوربه الساخنه من هذه الجهه مع
البطاطا وايضا للشوربه الع والتي تقدم منذ
عشره منذ سته سبعه ايام الى كل من يدخل
المدينه من اهلها او ابلا العاملين فيها
او من الذين ياتون من المناطق الاخرى
نشاهد ايضا الاستراحه للعمال الذين ياخذون
الان قسطا من الراحه بعد 24 ساعه وهذه
الخيام التي نراها وهذا المطبخ هو عباره
عن تقديم الطعام والدعم واللوجيسي لكل
الفرق ولكل الذين يمرون على الطريق حتى ان
الخبز والفاكهه وكل الاحتياجات من بطاطا
بالاضافه الى مياه هذا المطبخ هو صوره
مصغره عن مئات المطابخ الموزعه والمنتشره
على طول المدينه والتي ايضا قامت بها
الجمعيات
وقامت بها الجمعيات المدنيه وقامت ايضا
بها الحكومه واذهب معك الى هذه الصوره
المعبره جدا عن الالم لانتظار الذين تحت
الركاب لهذا العامل وايضا لاقاربه الذين
هم تحت الركاب هو يوقد
بنا ناري ماء يمكن ان يساعده ويخفف عنه
هذا البرد بالاضافه الى انه يبيت في
العراق